dostoevsky wrote in the idiot spoken
through the character of prince michigan
that beauty will save the world
soldien instant actually mentioned this
in his uh nobel prize
acceptance speech what do you think the
cs game meant by that was he right
well
i guess it's the divine that saves the
world let's say you could say that by
definition
and then you might say well are there
pointers to that which will save the
world or that which eternally saves the
world and
the answer to that in all likelihood is
yes and that's maybe truth and love and
justice
and
the classical virtues beauty
perhaps in some sense foremost among
them
it's a that's a difficult case to make
but definitely a pointer which direction
is the arrow pointing well the arrow is
pointing up no i think that that which
it points to is what beauty points to it
transcends beauty it's more than beauty
and that speaks to the divine
it points to the divine
yeah and i would say again by definition
because we could define the divine in
some real sense
so one way of defining the divine is
what is divine to you is your most
fundamental axiom and you might say well
i don't have a fundamental axiom then i
would say that's fine but then you're
just confused
because you have a bunch of
contradictory axioms and you might say
well i have no axioms at all and then
i'd say well you're just
epistemologically ignorant beyond
comprehension if you think that because
that's just not true at all but you
don't think a human being can exist
within contradictions
well yeah we have to exist within
contradiction but
when the contradictions make themselves
manifest
say in confusion with regard to
direction
then
the consequence of that technically is
anxiety
and frustration and disappointment and
all sorts of other negative emotions but
the cardinal negative emotion
signifying
multiple pathways forward
is anxiety it's an entropy signal
but you don't think that kind of
entropy signal can be channeled into
into beauty into love why does beauty
and love have to be clear ordered
simple
well i would say
it probably doesn't have to be
it can't be reduced to clarity and
simplicity
because when it's optimally structured
it's a balance between
order and chaos not order itself if it's
too ordered if music is too ordered it's
not it's not acceptable it sounds like a
drum machine it's too repetitive it's
too predictable
it it has to have
well
it has to have some fire in it
along with the structure
i was in miami doing a seminar on
exodus with a number of scholars and
this is a beauty discussion
when moses first encounters the burning
bush
it's not a conflagration that
demands attention it's something that
catches his attention
um it's a phenomena and that means to
shine forth and moses has to stop and
attend to it and he does and he sees
this fire that doesn't consume the tree
and the tree the tree is a structure
right it's a tree-like structure it's a
branching structure it's a hierarchical
structure
it's a self-similar structure it's a
fractal structure
and it's the tree of life and it's the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
and
the fire in it is the transformation
that's always occurring within every
structure and the fact that the fire
doesn't consume the bush in that
representation is a an indication of the
balance of transformation with structure
and that balance is presented as god and
what attracts
moses to it in some sense is the beauty
now it's the novelty and all that but
like a painting is like a burning bush
that's a good way of thinking about it a
great painting it's too much for people
often you know i my house
was and will soon be again completely
covered with paintings inside
and it was hard on people to come in
there because
well my mother for example say why would
you want to live in a museum
and i'd think well i would rather live
in a museum than anywhere else in some
real sense but beauty is daunting it
scares people
they're terrified of buying art for
example because their taste is on
display and they should be terrified
because generally people have terrible
taste now that doesn't mean they
shouldn't foster it and develop it but
and you know when you put your taste on
display it's a real really exposes you
even to yourself as you walk past it
every day
this is who i am yeah well and and look
how mundane that is and look how trite
it is and look at how cliched it is and
look at how sterile or too ordered it is
or too chaotic or how quickly you start
to take it for granted because you've
seen it so many times well if it's a
real piece of art that doesn't happen
you notice the little details the whole
is greater than the sum of the parts i
mean there are images
religious images in particular so we
could call them deep images
that people have been unpacking
for
4 000 years and still have i'll give you
an example this is a terrible example
so i did a lecture series on genesis
and i got a lot of it unpacked but by no
means all of it
when god kicks adam and eve out of the
garden of eden
he puts cherubim with flaming swords at
the gate to stop human beings from
re-entering paradise
i thought what the hell does that mean
cherubim and why do they have flaming
swords i don't get that what is that
exactly
and then i found out from matthew pagio
who wrote a great book on symbolism in
genesis
that cherubim are the supporting
monsters of god it's a very complicated
idea
and that they're partly a representation
of that which is difficult to fit into
conceptual systems
they've also got an angelic or demonic
aspect
take your pick
why do they have flaming swords well a
sword is a symbol of
judgment and
and
and the separation of the wheat from the
chaff use a sword to cut away
to cut away
and to carve
and a flaming sword is not only that
which carves it's that which burns
and what does it carve away and burn
well you want to get into paradise
it carves away everything about you that
isn't perfect
and so what does that mean okay well
here's part of what it means this is a
terrible thing
so
you could say that the entire christian
narrative is embedded in that image
why
well let's say that flaming swords are a
symbol of death
that seems pretty obvious
let's say further
that they're a symbol of apocalypse and
hell
that doesn't seem completely
unreasonable
so here's an idea
not only do you have to face death
you have to face death and hell
before you can get to paradise
hellish judgment
and all that's embedded in that image
and and a piece of art with an image
like that has all that information in it
and it shines forth in some fundamental
sense
it it reaches into the back tendrils of
your mind at levels you can't even
comprehend
and grips you i mean that's why people
go to museums and
gays at paintings they don't understand
and that's why they'll pay what's the
most expensive objects in the world if
it's not carbon fiber racing yachts it's
definitely classic paintings right it's
high level technological implements
or it's classic art well why are those
things so expensive why do we build
temples to house the images even secular
people go to museums
i'm secular well are you in a museum yes
are you looking at art yes well
what makes you think you're secular then
it's arguable that the thing
many many centuries from now that will
remain of all of human civilization will
be our art not not even the words well
you know the a book has remained a very
long time right the biblical reasons
that long
human
right
but that's in the full arc of living
organisms perhaps will not well we have
images that are we have artistic images
that are at least 50 000 years old right
that have survived
and some of those are
they're already profound in their
symbolism
yeah we found them
and and and
they've lasted they've lasted that long
and so and then
think about europe
secular people all over the world make
pilgrimages to europe
well why because of the beauty
obviously i mean
that's self-evident and it's partly
because there are things in europe that
are so beautiful they take your breath
away right they make your hair stand on
and they fill you with a sense of awe
and
and
we need to see those things it's not
optional we need to see those things the
cathedrals was in the cathedral in
vienna and it was terribly beautiful you
know terribly beautiful well it was
terribly beautiful is beauty painful for
you is is that the highest form of
beauty it really challenges you oh
definitely
yeah yeah i got a good analysis of the
statue of david michelangelo says you
could be far more than you are
that's what that statue says and this
cathedral you know down we went down
into the into the under structure of it
and there were three floors of bones
from the plague
and there they all are and then that
cathedral's on top of it
it's no joke to go visit a place like
that
no it's it it rattles you to the core
and our
our
religious systems have become
propositionally dubious but there's no
arguing with the architecture although
modern architects like to with their
sterility and their giant middle fingers
erected everywhere
but
beauty is a is a terrible pointer to god
and you know a secular person will say
well i don't believe in god it's like
have it your way
you gotta
you cannot move forward into the
unforeseen horizon of the future except
on faith
and you might say well i have no faith
it's like well good luck with the future
then because
what are you then nihilistic and
hopeless and anxiety-ridden
and if not well something's guiding you
forward it's faith in something or
multiple things which just makes you a
polytheist which i wouldn't recommend
you